LAURA LING: This is
Louis Bird, a 24-year-old
in the midst of rowing
2,400 miles from the coast
of California to Hawaii.
By the time he
finishes, the journey
will take 54 days
and 42 minutes,
in which Louis will rely
on the memory of his father
to survive the immense
challenge ahead of him.
Tell me about your
father, Peter Bird.
LOUIS BIRD: He was the first man
to row the Pacific Ocean solo,
in 1983.
It took him 294 days from
San Francisco to Brisbane.
And then after that, it
was just always in him.
PETER BIRD: I know that it's
just one oar-stroke at a time.
You don't want to take that
oar-stroke, but once it's gone,
then the next one's there.
It's just-- that's
all I can about it.
It's just like life.
LOUIS BIRD: My father
passed away in 1996.
I had five years with him.
I've got a few really
precious memories of him.
He was lost at sea in 1996.
He was rowing.
It was his fifth attempt
to row the North Pacific.
And about 1,000
miles into his trip,
they think that a
rogue wave hit him.
And they found his boat
floating upside down,
without any sign of my father.
So, that's why this particular
row in the Pacific Ocean
means so much to me.
I'm trying to get out there
and understand for myself what
it feels like to be on
a boat in the middle
nowhere for an extended
period of time.
LAURA LING: Have you
been on a boat before?
Are you a rower?
LOUIS BIRD: My experience
rowing is about six hours ocean
rowing.
Growing up, I've always
been terrified of water
I can't see the bottom of.
I've done lots of courses,
and I can navigate.
But as far as time in the
sea goes, I'm a real novice.
LAURA LING: What
do you ultimately
hope to get out of this row?
LOUIS BIRD: I believe
a lot that my father's
going to be out there with me.
And without putting too
much pressure on myself,
I hope to find a little
bit of bit of closure
in my father's death.
LAURA LING: After
months of preparation,
Louis set off from California
with his rowing partner.
LOUIS BIRD: OK, so we're
four days in, out here
in this bizarre alien world.
I have found it quite
hard to adjust out here,
if I'm being honest.
I'm missing friends and family.
It's tough.
I'm so tired.
At the moment, we're sleeping
about four hours a night
over a 24-hour period,
and rowing the rest.
PETER BIRD: I'm homesick.
I miss my family.
I miss Louis very much.
I miss him so
much, it's painful.
I really wonder what
the hell I'm doing here.
LOUIS BIRD: Warming up
OK in the next minute,
I'd rather be anywhere
else but here.
I'd like to see
some nice-- I want
to see a sunset and a sunrise,
some stars and a blue sky,
and I'll be happy.
It's just emotional, isn't it?
About everything.
Peter, my father-- he
must done this before,
this acclimatization period.
PETER BIRD: It's got me.
I'm just sick of
the whole thing.
I want to see something
green for a change.
It's just all blue, blue, blue,
and it makes me feel blue.
LOUIS BIRD: Finally, some
sunshine after-- what is it?
A week and a half now.
We turned everything
on its head.
There's light at the
end of the tunnel.
We might be about 450 miles
off the coast of Mexico.
Got 99 miles [INAUDIBLE]
So, we're on Day 20, and it's
been a beautiful day with sun,
as you can probably
tell by my burn.
I'm feeling close to
Dad, which is nice.
I had a very-- I had the most
vivid dream of my entire life.
Me and my mum were
painting someone's house,
and he just turned up at
the door unexpectedly.
We got to speak, and we
got to laugh and joke
for the first time.
I never had a dream that
vivid of him before,
and here I am in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean.
And it's all making sense.
PETER BIRD: It's my 180th
day at sea, and my birthday.
LOUIS BIRD: It is Day 29.
It's Day 30.
We're somewhere in the
Pacific, blah, blah, blah.
Over a month in this
boat, part of me
is looking forward
to getting to Hawaii
and joining real life again.
There were some dark
moments on the boat where
I've been in tears,
and just emotionally
coming to the place that holds
the end of my father's life.
I hadn't prepared for
the fact that it would
be as difficult as it has been.
But now I've kind of
made a breakthrough.
And I feel a lot more
confident on the boat.
We're over half way.
I'm enjoying myself.
LAURA LING: Do you feel like
this has sort of given you
a new purpose?
LOUIS BIRD: Absolutely.
It is, without a doubt,
the most important thing
I've ever done in my life.
And every single
stage has enabled
me to relate to a point
in my father's life.
And it's like unlocking
a door in somewhere
I could never get into without
taking on something like this.
We're four and a
half hours away.
We're 17 miles away.
We've nearly done it.
Look at that.
Land ho.
I can't believe it.
I can't even imagine
this is happening.
We've nearly made it.
It sounds a bit cheesy, but
he's completely within me.
And wherever I go,
he comes with me.
And I completely believe that.
We're both ocean rowers.
We'll always have
that now together.
I miss him.
And I hope that he's smiling
down from wherever he is.
[CHEERING]
LAURA LING: Don't forget to
subscribe for more Seeker
Stories.
And be sure to watch this
next episode in Hawaii,
where we go on the hunt to
understand how wild pigs are
damaging coral reefs.